the chances of mark ruffalo getting a
solo Hulk movie seem like they're slim
to none but the Hulk's been one of the
most visible superhero movie stars for
decades here's a look back at all the
Hulk movies ranked from worst to best
the last of three Incredible Hulk
revival TV movies was the death of the
Incredible Hulk
but despite the title and its status as
the final chapter banners death wasn't
meant to be permanent there was meant to
be a follow-up called The Revenge of the
Incredible Hulk but it never happened
possibly due to star Bill Bixby failing
health but more likely because death of
the Incredible Hulk got abysmally low
ratings the good news is that this meant
very few people got to see the moronic
manner of the Hulk's death he falls from
an airplane seriously that's it if
you're a fan of both the comics and the
show you learned a long time ago to
accept that TVs Hulk wasn't even close
to the comics version in terms of power
still the whole dying from a long fall
would be like Logan ending with
Wolverine dying from the flu part of the
goal of the late 80s Incredible Hulk
revival was to use a familiar face to
introduce some of the other Marvel
franchises to audiences that's why trial
of the Incredible Hulk was the debut of
the first live-action Matt Murdock aka
daredevil who represents banner after he
witnesses a crime linked to the kingpin
while daredevil fans likely wouldn't put
trial of The Incredible Hulk
any higher on a list than Hulk fans
would the movie gives way more attention
to the Man Without Fear than the green
Goliath while he makes a ruckus earlier
in the movie banners gigantic alter ego
doesn't even get close to the climactic
action during the final fight instead
pretty much everything is in the hands
of Daredevils badly choreographed
martial arts angley's Hulk is not well
loved but maybe it deserves a break at
the very least it was trying to be more
than just another popcorn action flick
the script isn't great and most of the
performances are wooden the story is
often boring with Lee waiting a long
time to introduce the Hulk and waiting
even longer for the film's only
impressive action scenes Hulk's battle
in the desert with the military the
effects are inconsistent with some shots
coming off as stunning and others are
embarrassingly cartoonish that said
there's a lot of mythic imagery Lee
connects the Hulk with nature which is
why he
works and moments with the Hulk
mesmerized by certain rock formations
and why it almost makes sense that one
of the most memorable fights in the film
comes when the Hulk takes on a bunch of
gamma-powered Hulk dogs almost Lee tried
to make something unique in entertaining
he thoroughly fails at the ladder but
you have to admit that he went for it
in 1988 American network television got
its first new installment of david
banners lonely saga since 1982 in the
made-for-tv movie The Incredible Hulk
returns along with Bill Bixby and Lou
Ferrigno return stars Eric Alan Kramer
as Thor and Steve Levitt as the Thunder
gods classic alter-ego Donald Blake it's
definitely pretty far from perfect but
of the three TV movies returns is by far
the most bearable unlike death The Hulk
doesn't die in a ridiculous way
and unlike trial the guest superhero
actually adds to the plot instead of
completely stealing the show Hulk and
Thor have their compulsory battle in a
lab almost 25 years before Chris
Hemsworth and Mark Ruffalo would tussle
on the deck of a Helicarrier or Duke it
out in an outerspace gladiatorial arena
admittedly their eventual team-up later
in the film feels way more like a fight
from an episode of the a-team than an
epic clash of strength between the
strongest Avengers but the fight is
still absolutely worth watching if
nothing else you can see how far we've
come since 1988 if this were a different
kind of ranked movie list there's a
really good chance of vengers infinity
war would make it a lot closer to the
top but as a Hulk movie it doesn't have
much to offer after that first opening
scene on the refugee ship the Hulk
pretty much disappears we see a few
flashes of green when Bruce Banner tries
and fails to get the other guy to come
out and it even has a couple of good
banner moments
[Music]
that's about it though and even worse
the Hulk totally gets warped if you're
not familiar with the Worf effect the
name refers to how often the
enterprise's Klingon security chief gets
beat up on Star Trek The Next Generation
it's an easy trope the bad guy beats up
the biggest baddest good guy early in
the story so the audience knows he's a
threat
The Hulk getting trounced and the nearly
vanishing would each be bad enough on
their own but together we eventually got
some good character development out of
it but for Hulk fans it adds up to some
surprising disappointment - infinity war
oh we got a lot to figure out pal
Incredible Hulk is probably not on the
top of anyone's list of MCU films but
the truth is it's probably a whole lot
better than you remember at the very
least it's not bad for one thing it
introduces the green Guide much sooner
than its 2003 predecessor for another it
gives us a lot more action in the form
of one classic Hulk villain the
abomination and the foundation for the
emergence of another in the form of dr.
Samuel Sterns a named Hulk fans would
recognize belonging to the master mind
villain the leader
it even has Stan Lee turning into a Hulk
and even if that happens off screen it's
definitely fun to think about plus it
stands to reason that Edie Norton could
have been the perfect Bruce Banner he
built his career playing characters who
were meek pushovers one second and
intimidating bullies the next
unfortunately his talents aren't really
used well in what amounts to a formulaic
action flick with no real glimpse of who
Bruce Banner is the CGI rendering of the
Hulk is definitely more consistent than
what we saw in angley's Hulk and the
monsters bellowing roar is a huge
improvement but watching Incredible Hulk
now the effects look primitive compared
to what we see in everything that comes
after for a Hulk fan age of Ultron was a
tough pill to swallow for the sake of
the plot Ironman needs to win their mid
movie tussle and as cool as it is to see
the Hulkbuster armor in action it raises
the question of why they even need the
Hulk around if Tony Stark can just build
something stronger whenever he wants it
does have some bright spots though
regardless of who wins the Hulk Iron Man
battle is wonderfully executed and in
the final conflict hoax probably the
only Avenger to successfully use his
teeth to trash robots
takes out Ultron in one shot twice there
are also some wonderful character
moments for Hulk an age of Ultron
whether you like the romances Black
Widow or not it reveals an interesting
side of banner we haven't seen before
while most of this list is for live
action flicks 2010's Planet Hulk is a
worthy exception based on the comic
storyline of the same name Planet Hulk
is about the green Goliath being exiled
by Earth's other heroes to the planet
Sekar where he becomes a gladiator and
eventually leads a revolt against the
tyrannical Red King Planet Hulk was
about as faithful to its source material
as a comic book movie could get stuff is
left out for time with the final battle
between Hulk and the Red King playing
out a little differently and the Holts
major gladiatorial battle is against
Thor's spacefaring buddy beta ray bill
instead of the Silver Surfer the biggest
change though is that it stops short of
the cataclysmic explosion that the comic
story ends with in the comics that acted
as a prologue to hold returning to Earth
for payback in the next storyline that
last omission however is one of the best
things about Planet Hulk because it
gives us something we rarely see in a
Hulk movie a happy ending
looking at 2017 s Thor Ragnarok through
the eyes of a Hulk fan can feel very
bittersweet on one hand it's the only
live-action adaptation of Planet Hulk
fans are likely to get but on the other
it's tough to know that the closest
we'll get to that story is a film
dedicated to one of the characters
biggest rivals how long have you been
like that like this big green stupid the
hoax dialogue perfectly captures what
any old-school Marvel fans should
remember of the savage Hulk's
monosyllabic speech but in the arena he
winds up having to unwittingly cheat to
win the fight voice activation required
burner
welcome strongest avenger what despite
the contradictions what keeps Ragnarok
so close to the top of this list is the
banter between Hulk and his best
frenemies Thor and all the comedic
moments that go along with it especially
the Hulk's dogged determination to take
down Serdar at the end and as a Hulk
film it's far from perfect but it's
still pretty great infinity war gave us
a lot of Banner and very little Hulk but
2019 Avengers end game rewards fans with
a lot of both by showing us a banner who
treating the Hulk like a disease and
used his genius to merge his mind with
the other guy's body we get to enjoy his
embarrassment at the earlier hulks
caveman persona and once the heroes
gathered the Infinity stones only Hulk
has the power to undo Santos's purge and
survive the ordeal we even get a tribute
to his classic Secret Wars feat of
holding a mountain range at bay
unfortunately the Hulk never gets
another shot at that us in fact he
doesn't get much time in the final
battle at all it's a pretty crowded
scene already sure but after their first
battle ended in such a crushing defeat
you really want to see as much smashing
as possible it's a little ironic that
2012's Avengers is above and beyond all
other Hulk movies not only is his name
not even in the title but he actually
isn't in it all that much the screen
time was limited to the film's two big
action sequences but that was enough for
him to completely steal the show and
provide him with a line that's every bit
as iconic as the classic don't make me
angry that's my secret
I'm always angry that moment marks the
final cohesion of the team and makes him
the movie's most crowd-pleasing star his
hilarious Sucker Punch on Thor in Grand
Central Station
the epic thrashing of Loki in stark
tower in the unique way that he helps
bring Tony Stark back to life are all
pure gamma-powered gold for the first
time Hulk's raw power on the screen
finally mirrors what we've seen in the
comics and the visual effects were never
more impressive before what we saw here
with the Hulk's face actually looking
like a green pumped up version of the
actor playing Bruce Banner just like an
English film we're made to wait quite a
bit to finally see the Hulk emerge the
build-up is perfect and there's enough
room in the movie for him to shine in
the time given unless the impossible
happens and Mark Ruffalo gets his own
solo Hulk flick the green Goliath is
unlikely to get a better portrayal than
what we saw in Avengers check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]